student activists nurse and noun
district councillor camellia is one of
nearly 400 local politicians elected to
a district council seat in a wave of
support for pro-democracy candidates
last November district councillors have
no direct governing role and deal mainly
with local issues but yam is hoping to
change things I think I will use about
17 to 18 percent of my time to do the
community work and then 10 to 20 percent
for the meetings in district council and
to our areas are perfect constant to the
political change the anti-government
protests in Hong Kong are into their
eighth month and while the intensity of
demonstrations has reduced a
pro-democracy march on New Year's Day
still attracted hundreds of thousands of
people many pro-democracy district
councillors have vowed to press on with
demands of anti-government protesters
and one of these is that the government
set up an independent commission to
investigate allegations of police
brutality during the protests so far the
government has agreed to one of their
demands the withdrawal of an extradition
bill that sparked the protests the
government has repeatedly said an
independent inquiry into allegations of
police misconduct is unnecessary and
that the existing police watchdog should
complete its review first that has
spurred many local politicians to take
matters into their own hands
as District Council's across the city
hold their first meeting since the polls
last year many have voted to set up
working groups to look into police
action in their area the pro
establishment side meanwhile has set up
a group to monitor how district
resources are used and it's already
planning a comeback for the next
election we realize a lot of people in
the society they care about family time
they care about you know of elements
recycling and stuff like this those are
the things that we do put a lot of focus
before and
in order to which out to you no more
more audience more voters I think that
that's the part that we will have to
focus on many pro-democracy supporters
hope their success in the districts will
also carry through into elections for
Legislative Council members due in
September but the challenge isn't the
same Legislative Council elections are
held on multi seed constituency single
boat system so this means that a
pro-democracy movement will have to
minimize the number of candidates so as
not to allow bowls to be too divided
although a landslide victory isn't
expected it's possible the Legislative
Council may see more pro-democracy
candidates and if that happens Hong
Kong's pro-democracy movement will be
expanding its fight from the streets
into the corridors of power
Florence lui al jazeera Hong Kong